are you Dax
Allen this mission Madeline yeah I saw
your simulation Oh
oh nice yeah let's trap you did a little
dive cool
I gotta get a dive into Dax now joy you
guys here improv workshop time awesome
all right it'll be super fun it gets
tough alright alright let's let's come
closer for the improv workshop can you
guys come to this table so thanks for
coming to the improv workshop everyone I
really appreciate it
my name's Alan sake on yeah yeah
so I host and produce a bunch of
different things science comedy shows
future festivals fireside chats all this
kind of cool stuff and I love meeting
epic people like you who come to cool
things like dense so I'm excited to get
to know you guys better
this is a improv session so we're gonna
be doing a little bit of quick
explanation kind of of some of the
improv and like the neuroscience by an
improv very quick and we're just gonna
get right in activities so we're gonna
get the juices flowing or the blood
going we're gonna be interacting with
each other and actually putting these
things to practice so if you're not
ready to put things to practice the
doors over there alright so neuroscience
behind improv a lot of people have said
that improv as is the root of creativity
improv is takes all the self referential
thinking that we have when we're sitting
there and we're thinking about ourselves
and how we look in front of other people
when you do that you're not actually
able to maximize your improvisational
ability so you get in a state of flow
and Michal e6m me javi is the guy that
we wrote the book about flow and it's
really accurate how many of us get lost
doing our activity and we just wake up
like the hour and a half later and yeah
yeah and you're just like whoa I forgot
to call mom I forgot to eat threat to do
all these things but boom I executed so
much stuff feels amazing yeah chat yeah
I love it there we go there we go there
we go yes yes yes awesome
so I want us to get the salt stand up
let's all stand up all right and now
let's do a little bouncing a little bit
of bouncing yeah yeah bounce yeah yeah
that's good yeah just a little bouncing
like that it's good
all right now I want us to say dent
okay put up but I'm gonna go one two
three and then we're all gonna go dent
okay ready one two three one two three
one two three yeah that's the universe
baby all right
so now pick a partner pick a partner
okay
who doesn't have a partner pick good all
right everyone's paired up okay cool
so now give yourselves give yourselves a
little bit of room so you guys in the
front come out a little bit
come on the come out a little bit in the
front uh-huh perfect keep calm maybe
some people take that middle alley area
you guys can stay back there perfect so
now all right now this this activity
we're gonna start very easy very easy
this is called the mirror game I'm sure
many of you have probably played this
before come on come on what's your name
what's your name Joey Alan come over
here come over here
all right so the mirror game is I'm
gonna just stand and just you're gonna
mirror every single one of my actions
okay
so if I lift my hand you're in try them
with mine you're only looking at their
eyes you're only looking at their eyes
so I might lift the foot I might maybe
like turn sideways or something I might
try and like wiggle around my fingers or
like do something crazy and see if the
person can fall but you're trying to
just watch their eyes and so just pick
one person do it for about 60 seconds
and then we'll switch okay have fun with
it okay all right all right so you go
back to the partner look at those guys
okay yeah let's do together
Xavier Alan nice to meet you right all
right so you go I'll mirror you I'll
mirror you all right
whoa I was fast oh you doing so hard
make it
ah yeah yeah I'm going backward alright
you can go if you want you try it I'll
see it let's see maybe we can oh that's
good that's good I like that one
alright let me alright let's switch
switch other person my fuel I've already
keep going go if you've already switched
keep going keep going now have a whole
like I have a whole Oh perfect then you
can be Javier's partner hi Sara
I'm Alan this tanishav yay alright so an
improv workshop we're talking just a
little bit about the neuroscience of
improv but then we just jump right into
activity so there's a mirror activity so
let her let her roll via and and look at
just the eyes yeah yeah
ah
awesome you guys are great give
yourselves a round of applause this is
really good stuff
really it's something all right now come
on in into one big circle now it's time
for one big circle they're doing this
whole hand thing where they put their
what do you do you put your middle
fingers in and you go like this or
something Church bit they're the people
yeah but is yes so what do we let's
let's close a circle off the close
circle off that's good okay I'll stand
right here okay so now the the this the
first sort of they're still doing it
they're loving this activity
how do I teach all there is how to do
that so all right so this activity is
called what is it what is it called Oh
move like this is the name of it okay
move like this so we're gonna go around
in a circle I'll start and then we'll go
to my right and we'll just each take
turns doing this but so the activity
goes something like this
my name is Alan and I move like this and
you just pick whatever action you want
and then the whole group goes his name
is Alan and he moves like this and then
we keep going around a circle okay so
let's practice together my name is Alan
and I move like but you you guys do it
after I do it okay because you won't
know what I'm doing right enough okay
now you know what I'm doing now sure
I'll change it up my name is Alan and I
move like this his name is Alan and it
moves like this perfect all right and go
ahead keep it up
and I move like this his name is Zack
and he moves like this her name is Kate
and she moves like this his name is Ray
and he moves like this his name is Rob
and he moves like this his name is wen
and he moves like this his name is Josh
and he moves like this his name is Doug
and he moves like this his name is Joey
any moves like this his name is Dax and
he moves like this his name is Greg and
he moves like this
his name is Dave and he moves like this
her name is Alice and she moves like
this his name is Bruce and he moves like
this whoa her name is Chris and she
moves like this his name is Xavier any
moves
like this name is Sara and she moves
like this nice round for everyone stop
what did you guys think of that activity
let's get some feedback
there is a whole nother one like that
and then usually gets like seven or
eight people before it fails but it's
fun it does fall apart but it's a fun
one too
yeah yeah okay yeah exactly you got
names you're signing in action there's a
group harmony yeah
yeah exactly alright so this one again
we're gonna be in a circle this is of
one word at a time storytelling yes one
word at a time storytelling so you're
only gonna say one word and we're gonna
go let's go to the left now we'll go to
the left and you're just gonna say one
word and you're gonna try make a
sensible story okay let's try and make a
fun story about how to dent the universe
or even make one silly whatever it may
be but don't take more than a second or
two to come up with your word don't
think too much go with that instinct of
what you want to say okay all right once
very high face okay weird story restart
okay story restart
it's great okay start one more dancers
are good job awesome that we actually
made it took three tries but we made a
full comprehensive fairly comprehensive
sentence very good okay let's do okay
this one this one's really fun so also
go all go actually I need to send
someone else in the center first so okay
volunteer Zach yep
yes come into this a yeah this our
background applause accepting yeah
that's it that's it I could dunno yeah
so we'll spend maybe like 30 or 60
seconds each in the middle and so what's
gonna happen in the middle is you're
just gonna receive rapid-fire questions
from people on the outside that are
either silly or serious like I could
tell you something like how many diapers
do you wear per week and see how quick
he answered right he's just like six
didn't think about it exactly yeah he
that's the actual amount I wear and then
I could I could also ask somebody else
could be like what's the definition of
time you'd be like
and that flows backwards something that
flows backwards so and don't necessarily
wait for him to even finish his answer
to the previous question so just keep
keep throwing him questions alright
let's go for a minute go how many colors
are in a rainbow how many moons of
Saturn half
all right yeah good stuff yeah all right
Kate yes Kate come on into the middle
all right so you're familiar with
activity now it seems pretty okay cool
cool and we have here's like I'll go to
the other side of the circle huh
all right so let's start it up what's
your third favorite color how many white
people live in Georgia will the Patriots
Super Bowl
definitely be scared of elevators
how many kids yeah how many planets are
there alright hey yeah alright come on
in what's your name again Raymond Ray
alright alright right here we go
why'd you pick that shirt today what do
you what are you preferring a woman
verge favorite sport sport cricket its
consciousness localized in the brain all
right right
your job to name again Rob awesome all
right Rob ready to young maverick
airspeed velocity of an unladen swallow
622
what's your favorite kind of clown who
open
must be the pigmentation in this who
owns a centralized banks in every
country if I give you a pogo stick would
you you dizzy yes
how many pogo sticks to your own why
favourite Kanye song Oh No yeah why you
to my wife alright get stuck rock the
next up Wayne yeah all right go ahead
one Batman or spider-man neither yes but
you don't want to see why not
it's waiting fun
where were you going
would you rather be mauled by one tiger
or 1 million Mouse's why nude is the
plural of mouse mice
what's the most food you can at one time
what's the last book you read
all righty get stuck stop everyone good
job Josh all right do you like babies
only the other ones how do you move like
this do you think genetic engineering
something to worry about
yes why because it would be fine
for a lot of people just going to
engineer themselves and that's scary
do you want a brain chip guard
what's your favorite position in the
bedroom well
Oh God
I am jelly yeah all right Joey how do
you why DS s so good genetics your own
Super Bowl what sort of food would you
put it
nachos
bring in the Beast I choose what's your
favorite
what's your favorite feel the science
Wow why
it's great to figure out lights and how
things work together and I'm the panic
country yeah job good job good job all
right - yeah jacks up no do you have a
comment often all the time not ever
weird little be a state in this country
what would the currency on Pluto be
don't you find it weird that we put
things in our mouth and comes out our
but it is pretty strange where do you
want to go what happens to that food
that goes into our yeah say questions
that launch it off
[Music]
why because I talked every morning with
Albert Einstein while I was waiting for
the bus to go to school is that actually
true yes what did you talk about I don't
remember I was 14 do you know what trade
that's all the nice
do you have kids three what do they do
questions good answers you're ready for
that one they're equal they're equal
there you call that's good good session
good job done yeah yeah job done
good job name Greg alright Greg's up
would you use a jetpack did you know
that you look a little bit like George
Lucas
alright you suck this up good answers
depression
alright Dave here we go what is the
least favorite letter in your should we
call a nice Mars yes why would you move
there do you like to be hotter cold was
maybe a cop-out answer
what's your favorite lift amazing job
here's fast your voice is gone okay yeah
that's good why'd you decide on the
hairstyle why'd you decide on the
hairstyle
what do you like most about Mary are you
worried about North Korea Roose Bruce
Ariana's the way Bruce Banner or Bruce
Wayne way Batman or spider-man
if someone
if someone could pour liquid on your
chest what would you choose and who
would do it
get on the toes this stuff
Chris alright outfit how'd you come with
outfit what characteristics do you join
a partner
the California condors would you spy on
people Reese's Cups or dolphins the
middle are their advanced civilization
smarter than us
where
[Applause]
Xavier right yeah yeah that's right all
right
what do you think's going on at the
White House shits going down do you
think those pants make your butt look
good
indestructible
for that suppose this text you exactly
reason especially part of that I'll go
back to exactly can you believe it a lot
yeah we don't want that back and put her
in the basket and close that different
okay get some soup
all right there you go
good job all right last but not least
who's your favorite person in the circle
did you know what that was before you
who's your worst relationship you've
been with this David you nervous about
cutting your hair short yeah
do you think Donald Trump has any good
characteristics what's his best
characteristic
who'd you vote for are we in a computer
simulation
why thoughts feedback what did you guys
think sure I'll go alright bring it on
bring it on to propel world peace and
Colin I star system no because I want to
see you guys in the middle but I love
doing this stuff no because we try and
help them because I start a science
comedy show two years ago I don't own a
dog and I do not recommend beating
anything except maybe your self
occasionally
I'm not concerned about that this is yes
what could potentially be an infinite
loop yes black holes could potentially
go into Big Bang's etc yes
we're or choose reflect eccentricity
what's your favorite science I do really
like astrophysics would you ever jump on
a moving train yes probably up until
about 20 miles an hour probably closer
to 10 miles an hour
I do think depending on the caliber of
maybe amount of neurons you know in that
being yes it does
my favorite shirt is probably I have
assured of Neil deGrasse Tyson going
like this no and if you do then be
careful love affair lover or fighter
lover and only fighting when it comes to
helping people I guess stupidest thing I
did last week was
this is where I fail what was my crew
gonna say I did last very good gosh good
job good job hey I got bailed out at the
last second I should have made something
up in that case exactly I was trying to
be honest through all those answers but
if you if you if you use some of you
guys chose to be just random and that's
good too if I would have been random
there that would have been perfect I
might have said something funny all this
kind of stuff so okay great what are we
at two ten okay so this this last
activity very last one now this is this
is probably the one that if we took away
something from this activity tonight I'd
want us to take this activity away so
let's start as a group and then we'll
break off into slightly more intimate
partners but this is kind of the thing
that's kind of propelled me to be Who I
am today and it's because of knowing how
to ask people deep thought-provoking
questions you've probably heard me say
like a couple times like something about
consciousness or something about being
in a simulation or if genetic
engineering is you know how it's gonna
impact the world and stuff like that so
I care about these like societal driving
questions but I also really care about
the intimate questions about where are
you from how many kids do you have what
do you care about what impact do you
want to make in the world so I want us
to do you guys have any questions like
that that you want to share with the
group that you love asking people when
you first meet with them what makes you
you that's a good one yeah
everyone has to like what are you really
good at what's that saying
yeah yes what do you care about yeah yep
why are you here
why are you here when was the greatest
lesson you learned in childhood that's a
good one yes good stuff yes yes you guys
this is amazing so these questions that
float up to the top of your head right
now in the circle these are the
questions that I would challenge you to
start conversations with people about
it's totally okay to talk about the
weather and the Super Bowl and stuff
like that it's totally cool but when if
you if you really want to figure out
someone you ask them why they are then
like why are you you and like what do
you care about what's the thing that's
most important to you what problem
you're trying to solve it said run by
asking these questions we typically go
from surface level immediately down deep
and we start actually having the deep
conversations with people so let's um
let's break up into groups of two and
let's ask yeah into group pairs into
pairs and then let's go go right away
look them in the eyes and let's have one
of the two people just ask a very deep
question and then remember you're you're
trying to follow up so when somebody
says you know when they ask well this is
really the important part pay attention
pay attention I know you guys probably
know this but when they say when you say
what do you care about and they say
maybe education it's you don't just say
okay or cool but you ask again why why
education what do you want to do in
education what impact do you want to
make that makes sense right so you're
you're continuing to deep dig deeper and
deeper are we on the same page
yeah let's let's let's find a new
partner and then we'll switch off after
a little bit okay okay
pair up pair up okay run across good
good awesome
awesome yeah yeah I may be started
welcome to do
yeah let's do it
yeah let's do it no one else right good
okay yeah ray that's right yes all right
come come to us let's take 0-60 let's do
a minute let's do a minute and then two
minutes then we'll switch in the world
good good some an idea turn okay a lot
of startup companies startup raise money
and things and I think
going forward as I get older I'd like to
do more consulting work yeah and just
really have others blossom around
actually is there specific area of
company that you really like financial
or biotechnology really is there some
sort of before technology wise my
background is in communication systems
okay but I have a client that makes
raters insects foods awesome they're
just a blast thing to hang out yeah yeah
exactly exactly cool so you have kids I
have three three kids cool and you're
happy they're all happy they're all good
I have I have a 25 year old here in San
Francisco as a biologist at Genentech
awesome Georgia Tech studying computer
science and they say honor which is the
reason why I'm here okay Jason invited
awesome we both sit on the hydrocephalus
association boy okay so my daughter has
no son and remind me that about that
again hydrocephalus it's a it's a fluid
drainage problem
for your cerebral blockage anywhere in
the path because it comes from the
center yeah yeah around the brain then
you end up with paralysis your brain
starts getting squeezed through the
inside so how do you prevent the
blockages so you don't mind my daughter
had she had a hemorrhagic stroke when
she was born so her right temporal lobe
doesn't work but her left side -
straight-a student where you SAT scores
but what they do is they drill hole in
your head oh my gosh she goes to high
dumps is this about a
mallika like a thousand people ten
thousand people in the u.s. in the world
in the US okay
that is insane very the great gratitude
we have for what we have yeah all right
all right all right
hello hello attention attention all
right did you guys already switch
between each other no yes you have okay
if all right if you haven't switched
between each other switch but if you
have already find a new partner okay all
right all right
so when what impact do you want to know
so so I think in order this is something
that I'm not completely sure about this
yet but in about ten years when I'm of
age I want to run for presidency I don't
know if the democratic election process
is gonna be the same as it is today
but I want to run on a couple things the
first things world peace but without
impeding innovation I still wanna have
peace and then the second thing is I
want to focus on steam so science
technology engineering art math one
focus on that in the world there are
things I want to eradicate all suffering
from the planet as much the radication
of suffering as possible examples like
your daughter are frequent in the
conversations that I have with people my
child died early my child and this is
just this is just crazy so there's so
many things to help us analyze our
bodies and prevent pathology from
developing and we're and so that's what
I care I care about that and then
another thing is meditation and
spirituality being able to connect to
this thyself and the last thing would be
to colonize other planets and stars
pressure points around the world yes
that's a really good question and I
don't immediately have an answer I'm
willing to talk to other intelligent
people around the world to try and
figure out how to solve some of those
pressure points especially and since
there are so many dozens of these
pressure points there are experts in
those areas that know them much better
but the overall idea of of awakening
people to find a more meditative or
peaceful state within themselves should
at least help the general population
gain a better understanding and desire
for peace but that's a very
generalization the pressure points are
very difficult very complex that's a
great follow-up question yeah exactly
yeah yeah
getting to that wannabes part you have
to solve there's a bunch of other issues
hapless saturated exactly oh yeah but
pulsing here oh yeah yeah he's a friend
yeah oh is it yeah good guy I just I
just finished good exactly yep exactly
exactly exactly yeah of course you have
to get one it's absolutely
indistinguishable yeah can't even tell
exactly yeah I'm glad you read that good
I'll have to let him know yeah say I met
someone I'd done to read a book and you
recommended it straight up like it was
like you know you you related it to
World Peace which is amazing you love
that yeah right expose exactly I did
like it's been for discussion about GMO
other things to make correct correct but
it's a very interesting thing if you
make 60 edits to corn or wheat or is it
still longitudinally safe for humans to
eat yes yeah yeah
alright everyone come back in come back
in come back in get stuff get stuff come
back in come back in in in circle circle
back in the circle we go you guys
looking like great conversations
happening back we go back we go come on
come on come on come on back we go good
conversations come on come on back we go
back we go back we go all right all
right all right
all right focus focus focus focus focus
come on tight tight tight tighter
tighter tighter tighter tighter tighter
tighter even tighter even say this is
good this is good
perfect okay yeah get comfy get comfy
okay so this is the end of the session
I'm happy that we were able to pass this
time together I love every single one of
you so much we're trying to make the eye
contact with every single person so wait
whoa oh yeah but here's the thing I want
you guys to be able to have fun and do
other things if US you know no I
actually don't you know you hours if you
yeah nothing nothing nothing
seriously if you guys say that you want
me until 3:30 I will seriously stay
until through 30 I was well I was just
trying no really I just any you guys
actually want to show fans you're not
gonna offend me if you want to leave
that's why I was oh you're smearing me
now what was my plan for us pretty much
additional activities and going diving
deeper into conversation and intimacy
and and then flow and stuff like that
and yeah but yeah but I skits
we can do skits I love skits I'm an open
person I have no like we don't have to
follow anything
no but skits is amazing yes yeah yeah
you were writing you're right here okay
what what is it regarding public
speaking that you don't wait why does it
feel like it's talking at people
okay but what why can't it feel more
like teaching like sharing sharing
sharing wisdom right you have you you're
the reason why you're giving a talk is
because you're sharing something that
other people might not know and they
might want to care about and when once
we once we take that perspective when we
shift it from from fear to beauty into
sharing and caring then that that energy
in itself that change in your physiology
will change the way that you feel about
speaking yeah I'm really happy to stick
to stick around and talk more about that
that's a good question exactly have you
guys experienced this you know when
you've signed up to go do something and
then like it's like maybe 15 or 30
minutes before you're scheduled to like
leave to go do that thing and you're
like god I just want to stay at home I
don't want to go right you guys no
feeling and then you get there and you
start hanging out and you're like oh
this is fun and like I'm happy I left my
house I'm happy I'm doing this thing you
guys know that feeling yeah board games
yeah yeah exactly exactly
so um yeah that kind of a feeling
happens to just about everyone and
sometimes it is better to you know stay
home and do some work or whatever you
want to do but it's also good to get out
and do your thing
so I'm serious I'm totally down to stick
around another whatever 45 minutes or an
hour however Long's left I don't even
know what time is it
yes hour so so I host introduced science
comedy shows so I have a guest scientist
that comes in and gives a talk about a
specific subject and asked audience
questions comedians will crack jokes
through the whole thing and then I
produce these future festivals called
World's Fair so a bunch of people come
in and play with arv our drones electric
sabers 3d printers and then there's a
thousand seat speaker stage that goes on
talking about the future of AI future
gene editing
and then I have a fireside chat series
called simulation does anyone who joined
Peterson is so know who Jordan Peterson
is it's a culture critic it's
interesting guy you do oh I'm hosting a
fireside chat with him in San Francisco
in a 600 seat theater so it's like stuff
like that it's kind of yeah is what I do
and yeah yeah
great question yeah yeah yes yeah oh
it's what this person has just said and
we build on it you're not saying lots of
dumb you just take it and go with it
yeah that type of attitude to in a group
dynamic you get two very interesting
places yep that's huge it's huge all
these exercises help you like yeah and
it's also more kind